salut à tous c'est la première fois en huit
ans qu'un événement d'actualité
me parait si important que je ressens le
besoin d'en parler sur ma chaîne en
anglais
ce dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui me semble encore plus important
que  convoité 19.
nous allons parler du limogeage
du dr timmy cabu co-directeur de l'
équipe d'éthique ai de google
et chercheur universitaire de renom
il y a donc encore beaucoup d'inconnues
dans cette histoire en grande partie parce que chaque
partie essaie de se protéger
légalement mais  le tldr de ma compréhension
dans lequel j'ai une énorme crédibilité est
que la direction de google a
censuré une publication par son équipe d'éthique ai
qui est quelque chose de profondément inquiétant
car comme j'en ai longuement discuté
sur ma chaîne
et comme c'est discuté beaucoup plus
longuement  dans notre livre lu fabuleux,
il est sans doute devenu urgent de réfléchir
à l'éthique des algorithmes de
google
et d'autres sociétés de technologie, car ils
sont utilisés par des
milliards d'humains sur terre en raison de
la  y influencent inévitablement grandement les
informations auxquelles des milliards d'entre nous
seront exposés au quotidien
mais il y a de bonnes nouvelles dans tout
cela et même une excellente
nouvelle suite au licenciement de son coéquipier kobo les
employés de google ont
écrit une lettre ouverte collective
protestant contre le licenciement et réclamant
trois  choses de la direction
une explication supplémentaire sur la censure de
la publication
deux plus de transparence envers le
grand public,
y compris vous et moi trois un engagement unique d'
oracle envers l'intégrité de la recherche
et la liberté académique et le respect des
principes de la philosophie de recherche de google et des principes de l'IA de
google au  le temps que
je filme cette vidéo
la lettre a été signée par un total de 2040
employés de google
et 2 658 individus de l'
industrie universitaire et de la société civile et parmi
eux
il y a moi donc 2040 c'est beaucoup
mais google c'est presque une centaine de
milliers d'employés
donc c'est quand même  une petite fraction de tous
les employés de Google
et comme pour 2658
bien c'est al  ce que j'aimerais le plus décevant,
c'est que ces
chiffres soient au moins de l'ordre de dizaines
de milliers,
donc la principale raison pour laquelle je fais cette vidéo
est d'essayer de convaincre davantage d'entre vous de
soutenir
l'échelle ouverte non seulement pour soutenir
coéquipière gabru
dont le licenciement s'est déroulé dans
des conditions très étranges
notamment de l'avis de son propre
manager qui l'a appris
après coup mais aussi et surtout pour
soutenir les
recherches et les discussions sur l'éthique
des algorithmes
non seulement chez google mais aussi dans les autres
entreprises
du monde académique et au-delà oui
parce que
cette lettre n'est pas une réaction à une
simple actualité
c'est une réaction à une censure de la
recherche sur l'éthique des algorithmes les
plus sophistiqués et les plus influents au monde
aujourd'hui la recherche google répond à des milliards
de requêtes par jour
et l'algorithme de recommandation youtube est
responsable de 70
des milliards de vidéos vues sur la
plateforme soit
deux fois sur trois lorsqu'un
individu wa  tches une vidéo
c'est parce que l'algorithme de youtube
recommandait
cette vidéo cependant de nombreuses recherches
montrent que l'impact de cet algorithme
a longtemps été catastrophique
avec des théories du complot qui font des
millions voire des milliards de vues cumulées des
vidéos qui nient le changement climatique qui
font presque autant de vues
que celles qui  expliquez-le et le contenu
qui propage des informations erronées dangereuses sur la santé publique, à l'
inverse, des vidéos de haute qualité pourraient
faire beaucoup plus de vues
si google était plus disposé à promouvoir
des
informations fiables récemment chez google, il y
a eu beaucoup de progrès éthiques tels
que le recrutement de son coéquipier gobu en
le  investissement dans l'équipe ai éthique elle
a bâti
les nombreuses publications académiques de cette
équipe ou encore la prestigieuse
conférence équité responsabilité transparence
que son coéquipier gabriel a contribué à créer
et qui est organisée par l'acm
l'association internationale pour
la
recherche en informatique mais plus généralement tous ces
signaux  Ha  ont certainement contribué à créer
une culture au sein de google
qui sensibilise les chercheurs et les ingénieurs
aux risques de leurs algorithmes
et qui met la pression sur la direction de google
comme ce fut le cas lorsque les
ingénieurs ont refusé de collaborer avec
l'armée américaine
dans une certaine mesure ces avancées éthiques
ont été validées  par l'ajout de
bannières pendant la crise du coving 19
qui redirige vers wikipedia ou vers le
site Web de l'organisation mondiale de la santé ou par l'audit externe de
différents groupes ou chercheurs
qui montrent que youtube a diminué la
recommandation de désinformation dangereuse
sur certains sujets, mais selon
ces articles,
cela  est encore largement insuffisant et
nous avons besoin de beaucoup plus d'investissements
dans les équipes d'éthique et de sécurité de l'IA chez
google,
mais au moins nous devons reconnaître qu'il
y a eu des progrès clairs,
y compris des collaborations avec des
universitaires externes pour étudier les impacts sociaux des
algorithmes de google
comme dans le cas  de la célèbre publication
de timmy gabu et  ses collègues
ce qui semble avoir été accepté au
départ par la direction de google
mais le licenciement de son coéquipier gabriel
porte gravement atteinte à cette culture de
responsabilité éthique
surtout il envoie le mauvais type de
signaux à chaque employé de google
ne remettez pas en question nos produits ou vous
serez viré
c'est critique  qu'il y ait une
réponse proportionnée à cet horrible
signal
à mon avis jusqu'à présent, la réponse est
bonne mais elle n'est pas encore
proportionnée pour qu'elle soit
proportionnée,
il est essentiel que cet opérateur reçoive
beaucoup plus de soutien
de beaucoup plus de personnes à la fois de  à l'intérieur de
google mais aussi
de l'extérieur c'est l'occasion pour nous de
dire à google que nos inquiétudes concernant
leurs algorithmes
ne peuvent pas être balayées sous le tapis pour exiger
plus de transparence et
surtout de valoriser beaucoup plus
les dimensions sécuritaires et éthiques
de leurs algorithmes compte tenu de l'influence
que les algorithmes de google  aujourd'hui
et les inquiétudes à avoir sur la
qualité des informations diffusées
sur internet il me semble que
c'est
critique pour l'avenir de l'humanité
en effet le signal que nous envoyons à
travers cette lettre
ne doit pas se limiter à google c'est
aussi l'occasion de dire à la
direction d'autres entreprises
facebook twitter amazon microsoft ou
apple
que l'éthique de leurs algorithmes doit
être prise très au sérieux
et que toute préoccupation soulevée en interne
ou en externe
doit être traitée avec soin et respect
c'est aussi l'occasion de dire à tous
les chercheurs en informatique
que l'amélioration des performances des
algorithmes qu'ils conçoivent
ne doit pas être  la principale préoccupation, même
aujourd'hui, il est beaucoup plus cool et beaucoup plus
précieux
de découvrir un nouvel algorithme qui résout
le problème plus rapidement que les
algorithmes précédents ou de montrer que certaines
implémentations peuvent atteindre des performances
selon certaines métriques d'un facteur 1,5
que de soulever et de résoudre des problèmes éthiques
avec tel ou tel déploiement
de tel ou tel algorithme de tels articles sur l'
éthique ou la sécurité sont beaucoup  plus facilement
rejetées par les revues par les pairs
et les chercheurs qui y participent
auront donc moins d'
opportunités d'emploi
pour rester dans le monde académique plus
généralement nous donnons actuellement de très
mauvaises incitations
à la recherche publique enfin cette lettre ouverte
est l'occasion de le dire à d'autres
chercheurs d'autres disciplines
que s'ils font eux-mêmes des recherches sur
les enjeux éthiques des algorithmes sur
les réseaux sociaux
ils seront écoutés et non ignorés
ou poursuivis
par des organismes comme google en
particulier il me semble primordial que la
recherche
en éthique soit faite à la fois par des
chercheurs de google qui analysent des
algorithmes et  des données que seul google possède
et qui sont difficilement partageables pour
des raisons de confidentialité
mais aussi et surtout cette recherche
devrait se faire aussi en dehors de google
où la liberté académique
permettra de critiquer plus facilement les produits de google
et donc d'éviter un certain lavage éthique
qui est malheureusement bien trop  commun de
nos jours, faisant des algorithmes à grande échelle des
avantages robustes  icial
est une entreprise fabuleuse mais pour l'initier
il est urgent que nous montrons que nous nous soucions
suffisamment
d'elle et la meilleure façon de le faire
aujourd'hui
est sûrement de signer la lettre ouverte dont le
lien
est dans la description